cube this is a movie that's been kicking
around for a while it finally came
together what was holding it back was it
the idea that nobody could agree of what
the movie was supposed to be and what
did you want that movie to be well you
know I think the reason it took so long
is because you know it took a lot of
courage to make this movie you know it
really did thank you and you know we had
a couple of nibbles but you know really
Donna Langley over a universal really
stepped up and we was so grateful to her
because she promised me and Gary and
Scott that we'd get to make the movie we
wanted to make and she kept her word to
us and you know once we had you know
somebody like her in our corner we
really just started going for it and you
know me and Gary knew the kind of movie
we wanted to make you know everybody
knows the where and the what but not too
many people know the why you know why
did we create this kind of music and we
wanted to have a film that was not just
a story about rap but a slice of
American life a slice of history that
changed a lot of things you know it's
the world before NWA and it's the world
after in the VOA and you know we we
think you know the audience deserves to
see this story and how it all took place
and I'll be real quick you know people
been entertained by the NWA family tree
for over 25 years and we believe that
they should see where it comes from they
should all see how it all started and
thank God we was able to do straight out
Gary you've got your fine cast right
next to you what were you looking for in
casting it how important was it that
they look a little bit the part I'm
looking at you O'Shea how important was
it that they could maybe sing a little
bit but how important was that they had
a soul that they had the character that
they understood who these people were
well first of all I want to just really
give props to my casting director Cindy
Tolan and Vicky Thomas they did an
amazing job I'm pretty tough I'm pretty
tough and this was the hardest part
about making this movie casting it
because you know there are a lot of NWA
fans out there and people still really
have Dre and cube in their consciousness
right now especially as it relates to
beats and movies and things like that so
we had to get it right my first priority
was performance performance performance
you know then came the performance on
stage do I believe they these guys on
stage can they rap and then there was
street credibility do I believe these
guys are from Compton can they pull off
the street credibility thing and then
the likeness was last you know I we I
think we really scored with the fact
that these guys really look like these
guys but when the novelty of the
look-alike thing wears off they have to
carry a movie did they carry his movie
guys thank you so it was really really
important it was just really important
to make sure they could perform and this
is probably one of the hardest jobs I've
ever had in terms of putting a story on
the screen and we really put these guys
through in terms of boot camp and
everything and I'll let them tell you
the stories don't be too hard on me
just you know how be hard on but um this
is this is an amazing feat and these
guys really did a great job and my
casting directors really did a great job
as well okay I'm gonna start with you
you have got you've got some big shoes
to fill you're playing your dad what
were the conversations that you had with
your father was not only your father
he's the producer of the film and you're
playing him was that intimidating for
you and how did you jump into that all
the pressure that
was placed on me was placed by myself
you know this is my family's legacy and
that was really the pressure on Phil the
times where he would be on set you know
it would really call me to see him you
know it I took it as an opportunity to
show them what I can do you know it took
me two years of auditioning two years of
different coaches I work with hearing
spies or Susan Batson and so you know I
really wanted to show my progress where
I went with it the pieces of advice that
he would give me were what he was
thinking at those certain days within
the film you know anything that I can
use as ammunition as an actor you know
being able to ad-lib off of anything
when I when I feel the character would
say so you know those were just pieces
of advice he called me every day before
I went to set before I went to work just
to make sure where my head was at where
his head was at and you know giving me
my ammo and let's be clear we did not
give him this role not at all you know I
wanted to spill any rumors or any
thoughts about nepotism or anything like
that this guy worked the hardest to get
this part he worked for two years for
callbacks and screen tests and chemistry
tests and things like that and all over
to the last minute he wasn't really sure
he's gonna get this role but I want to
let everybody know he worked the hardest
to get the role and he I think he
learned a lot in that process and I
think that's the reason why his
performance is world-class
Corie another one of the producers on
this film was dr. Dre who you play a
little bit intimidating and what kinds
of conversations that you have with Dre
about what he wanted in this performance
and did you feel that you had the
liberty to create a performance that was
separate from an imitation of who he was
today a little intimidating might be
understatement now it was a it was it
was sort of an opportunity of a lifetime
to be able to to take to take his legacy
and translate that or part of it and
translate that to film I remember when I
initially you know it heard about the
role I kind of ran away from it in the
beginning I um my agent called and he
was like you know we got this this this
this NWA movie coming up and they want
you to come and I'm like oh great cool
cool cool what role names like dr. Dre
and I was like no no man I don't know if
I can pull that off man no no you know
because for me I was going through the
sort of actor insecurities all the
things that you sort of do you doubt
yourself and and not many people run
away from from opportunities like this
but I did but one thing led to another
and I remember just you know skyping
with Gary and knowing that he was on the
movie and knowing that Dre was gonna be
this involved and Q was gonna be this
involved there was no way I could not do
this you know and and who else you know
that's what you kind of have to tell
yourself so yeah man I got out to LA and
I remember I met Dre for the first time
and he said I'm not interested in you
doing an impersonation or mimicking me
or try to you know look and act and
study this and that he was like I you're
trained you got that you know what I
mean you you I trust that I just want
you to capture the essence of what NWA
represented and so it took a weight off
the shoulders but at the same time I
added another after the two months of
prep we had to actually show up and do
it so it was a blessed blessed
opportunity Jason I want to hear you
were obviously on the opposite situation
Eric is no longer with it easy is no
longer with us but his widow is and I'm
curious what kinds of conversations what
kind of material you ever get from
Tameka Wright's woods to help you in
this part
you know every man who works has a point
where they go home and they talk to
their wife you know and they talk to
their kids and they do all these things
that actually matter in real life you
know so for me I wanted to know after
the all these hard days are after all
these you know moments that are
considered considered iconic in these
guys lives what were the conversations
after those moments you know and she
could really give me some gold on that
you know and besides she had a bunch of
great tapes and they had like they had
really really really bad stuff back then
like like when it came to technology so
they would have like these huge
thirty-six minute takes of a bunch of
mess ups and you would really see that
their chemistry between each other you
know and how he was kind of a leader in
the situation and just you know things
that were really really really vital
when it comes to showing the essence of
a person and the real Humanity of a man
you know in the leverage of him but I
know they had so many people who wanted
me to hit the mark you know there has so
many people these guys are my Easi II
you know I mean like for real like they
they'd look at me and they like yo this
to dude who pretty much figured me out
in my situation you know what I mean
like they helped me get to the next
level in my situation so you can mess
this up and I could lose my footing yeah
it's over you know however it may turn
out you know but yeah man you know it's
a life-changing situation Scott this is
a this is a obviously a period film
whose timing leanness just changes by
the hour and by the week and I'm curious
as an executive looking at this project
with one eye with one set of eyes and
looking at what's happening at the world
and another set of eyes what are the
conversations that you have with Gary as
the world is changing us this movies
being made about what this film needs to
be in what it has become through no
fault of its own you know that's a great
question I mean you know Gary and I in
cube everyday from the moment we sat
down and sort of put our hands in the
middle and said we're making this movie
when Donna gave us that license to be
creative and to tell the story that
these
I wanted to tell and from the get-go
they wanted a you know they want to tell
a story that paralleled the worlds in
the 80s and 90s it's a day and during
the first week of shooting which was the
last week it happened to fall on the
first night of the Ferguson riots the
night we shot the exterior at Jenks
house with O'Shea with with Ice Cube
when he got harassed leaving that
evening it was going on and we didn't
even know it and the next morning we
woke up and cnn.com had a police car on
fire with FTP across it I immediately
called cube and called Gary we had a you
know a real conversation about the
responsibilities filmmakers we weren't
here to stoke the fire we were here to
make a conversation and this film
ultimately took on an importance that we
didn't realize that we were doing in the
beginning we always knew we weren't just
making a biopic you can see from the
movie from you open up in a battle Ram
and police and you end on someone
passing away and this isn't a that we
said to ourselves from the get-go we're
not telling an A to B story
we're telling not just the story of NWA
we're telling the story of everybody
else
everybody's perspective of the world and
it began to really run a parallel so
every day we would all have
conversations on the scenes we were
shooting what I really meant what a
minute then what I meant today yeah but
I want to hear I'm gonna end with Gary
I'm gonna end with our filmmaker cannot
speak oh yeah yeah you can speak okay
you know I wanted to do this movie with
you know who was a short list you know I
had two people that I wanted to do this
movie with and if they both would have
turned me down I probably wouldn't
wanted to do it and that was Gary gray
and my man John Singleton and because
not because you know we're friends and I
know he's great but he's so passionate
about filmmaking and he's passionate
about making the movies the right way
and you know some people like to dialing
in and you know with this movie it was
like all the ingredients for hit so you
know I was like yo you got the cars you
got the women you got to dis you know
let's go
make a movie but gary was like no where
is the humanity we're we don't we don't
we already know about cars and and
rapping and this and that but do we know
about five friends do we know how it
happened for five individuals that can
be any one of us and you know that's
what makes him a special filmmaker is
the fact that he goes deeper than
everybody else wants to go to pull out
these kind of performances this kind of
story that works on so many levels so
that's just what I want to say about my
friend okay
and Gary you're the filmmaker you get
the last word as we're walking out
tonight what do you hope people take
away with them from this moment um I
just want everybody be inspired you know
just look beyond the obvious you know
this movie has a few metaphors in there
and if you look closely you watch a
couple times you see what we're trying
to say and cube is dope because he's
like listen this movie is so much bigger
than NWA so much bigger than the music
I'm okay with you making that version of
this movie you just had no ego
whatsoever the good the bad and the ugly
and I want people to look at this movie
and saying you know what if a few kids
from Compton can start in a garage and
end up changing their lives changing
their reality maybe I can do it myself
and that's basically what you do and
thank you cube Gary
O'Shea Cory Jason Scott thank you